radio show host Tammy Bruce joins us
tonight she's been watching carefully
so it's interesting I mean it's so if
you're making the case that Trump is
kind of out there and he says things
that are ill-considered and he's profane
you know that's all kind of true
wouldn't your response be I'm the
responsible one instead they're out
trumping Trump by like 3x and they've
gone so crazy that they made out even
win the house back why are they doing
that well look at these women are making
Trump at this point look like Sir
Galahad exactly when it comes to their
behavior and I think his third and
fourth terms at this point have been
pretty much secured after the these
display stuff lecture this is it's not
new I mean what's happened is because of
their rage that the curtains been pulled
back they just don't care about hiding
the nature of who they are
you didn't mention Sally Field Sally
Field the actress The Flying Nun have
also defended the use of the c-word and
at the same time what she's saying is
what they're trying to do is normalize
the debasement of women in the name of
being able to attack a woman with whom
they disagree because they think she's
conservative but of course the irony is
Ivanka is not a conservative
it is a meltdown but it is a reveal also
I think why someone like Weinstein could
survive so long in that works right when
you when you're willing to reduce and
have no principles when you refuse to
stand up for what's right because
someone's a political opponent that
anything goes so the American people are
seeing what this means they're seeing
that that this is certainly not a
framework not only of their values but
of an kind of an ugliness now at the
same time look people in media make
mistakes on the fly that we know this
you genuinely can regret something and
apologize the problem with what the
Samantha B dynamic represents which is
different in to some degree from grows
and bar who's doing a tweet it was
scripted it was fairly edited with with
an editing team then it was taped then
it aired then it was put on social media
and it was promoted and when those vile
misogynistic words started to trend on
Twitter her executive producer was
excited well so that's the thing
by the way we should point out that she
works with a network that owns CNN look
I mean I've worked in newsrooms my whole
life I use vulgarity I enjoy it I you
know I don't want to be a Bluenose about
it but that one word that she used I
don't know any man who uses that word
because it is kind of the one word that
is actually degrading it's the thing
that feminists always telling us that
word really is why that worked it's
fascinating it reduces us to up to a
vile terminology to a part of our body
into the ultimate debasement of who we
are as women and this has transcends
politics and party and everything else
this is about a loathing and hate they
have no other they have no ideas they
see the president is successful we
should all be happy that he is because
of the nature of what he's been up a
becau because they don't know how to
counter it
it returns into this you know ultimately
it's the fraud of people like
Schneiderman or Weinstein the nature of
this kind of attack the misogyny that
was my first book in 2001 that misogyny
and sexism the homophobia racism lives
on the left and again it's not about if
you don't like something someone has
said we can all deal with that right we
can and we've all we've all made
mistakes this is a concerted scripted
attitude and then for other women to to
support it and try to normalize Sally
Field it was well liked to some degree
to try to normalize this debasement
means we've they at least have gone off
the rails yeah I mean I you know I get
the people have you know disagreements
with Trump but these people are scary I
mean I don't think they should be
anywhere near power they're starting to
really scare me I'm not just saying that
I watch this stuff every day anyway
Kenny great to see you thanks for having
me smarter than us as always thank you